Welcome Back to the 2021 Director's Close-Up this
year! For the very first time we have introduced
television categories into the Spirit Awards.
Small Axe Unorthodox Little America Lee Eisenberg
Emily V. Gordon and Kumail Nanjiani Steve
McQueen Anna Winger. Take it away! I mean these
films should have been made when they occurred,
they wanted to go straight into people's homes
straight into the bloodstream of Britain really.
It's an anthology series stories of immigrants
who've moved to America every episode has
a different cast a different tone and so
we weren't sure we were going to be able to make
it. Different types of stories, different types
of experiences, some stories take place over the
course of a week some span 15 years trying to find
the narrative through and there's no one immigrant
experience. It was an amazing experience we had an
amazing dialogue about jewishness among the
people both behind the camera and on set.
You write the thing that you want
to see I think that's the best!